welcome to this video playing go good
chess okay let's see I can do something
with good chess default yeah okay come
on let's play the open and what do we
get ok this one the classical Sicilian
as it is often called then playing the
browser variation I only have a very
vague idea to play that there is f4 but
there's also f3 so this term should be
should be quite ok I think mm-hmm going
for a quick before yeah let's let's put
the king will be one very hard to to get
along without this in the long run ok
ticks and Bishop b3 for some development
and then I can go G 4h for those kind of
things before 92 should always be ok
yeah hmm that's always interesting if
they play move like age 6 cm ok i will
retreat of course but it can be
weakening on the King side however maybe
black can put in a quick g5 here I
didn't do that so let's let's push him
quickly
d5 now there's g5 a.m. and de for takes
on f6 will win a piece so g5 is is
really a bit awkward okay so what about
this I wonder if I should go FYI prevent
95 or g5 immediately g5 h 5 g six maybe
FYI sorts of weakening the e4 pawn tried
considerably okay let's push and not
think about it for too long very often
in this assay and you should just go go
for the most aggressive museum and don't
think about it for too long only f4 I
was thinking yeah I know it allows
Knight to f3 of its still now g-49
convincing okay let's do it anyway as
mentioned it's a case of fire first and
then think about it I green g2s Nigerian
g6 should be really dangerous or black
he decided on Nyjah one really quickly
so okay rook takes Bishop f6
but then I have if I am I have a 5v5
details Bishop c5 check King g8 Quint
xf64 disaster I think maybe yes to play
a printf seven maybe chat let's check
assume quite dangerous to put it put it
very mildly so kingi age is there
something even better than Queen takes
f6 I wonder probably not e six is also
hanging which is quite useful so Queen
f7 am is there winning tactic here I
mean I'm very reliable to miss winning
tactics in this type of situation so
think about it for a moment arm is it
just straightforward stuff I can take
and take on e5 this is this will win I
guess but I don't seek let's play that I
don't I don't see a maid so I'm going
for that this is two pieces and a
fantastic position so especially
considering how weak is king is and his
pawns on Bishop g6 is especially
problematic check and the test to
retreat but I can can do this first
Knight to f4 serve quite something as
well
92 to f1
oh is this a little bit nervous about
this Bishop doing some discovered
discovered move but there was never
really really dangerous one can take on
d5 but then you will take on see fire I
don't want that would be nice to get in
Bishop g6 check and then check on d5
then the e pawn what just promote what's
really miss Tripp g6 first can we played
check yeah I know my usual motto keep it
simple and the e porn is some is
promoting I think there's also stuff
like bishop f7 check King moves Bishop
g5 so nah this is over black resides
yeah I wonder if there was a direct
direct win now I mean this is maybe a
little bit fishy but it's the kind of
aggressive play left you have to do in
this is saying it cannot just sit around
and wait and I think really that you
should play Knight g4 I wasn't clear
what should it wasn't clear to me what I
should do then maybe if I know Queenie
to look g4 or something like that but
this is definitely a better better
defense this move is not really helping
because of before it neglects this cover
but here I mean this is at least very
dangerous but here maybe he has to
improve somehow I don't know Bishop f6
was played and I Wendy 5
Luke age 6 he's got Luke age 6 which I
didn't really think about honey Lou
movie i Luke age 6 now assume as much
much better of course I have to go back
and thinks I it seems that this is a
good try leading to a very sharp
position tending now again Bishop c5
business I am taking only five at the
right mode computer actually assesses
this is completely equal to in a Cell
raid and this is a great resource you
can play this however and back and be
sure therefore as a perpetual her
petition of moves that's funny okay in
the game he went with this but now
Bishop c5 is winning him so okay I could
have taken on g7 what why is it possible
I mean I was just seeing the other line
wins and I went for it yeah because I
didn't want to spend so much time here
okay well this is very straightforward
actually you know what I didn't see what
I didn't see is quite simple I didn't
see that here Catholic my boo show is
covering this gray I am he has to play
Queen f7 and then I can i just pick up
yeah takes yeah and now I mean I'm just
attacking here with him with everything
95 it looks fantastic and the computer
is on plus 20 but it's it's something
that you have to play first okay well i
wasn't seeing that cat saw that this is
a winning position and i went for it
yeah maybe it was a it was a good choice
in a practical blitz game because here
it's really easy to play now he just
bring the pieces check towards the king
and now the e porn
us a home run maybe practically speaking
this was was was even better yeah it's
very easy to win and you don't run any
risk of doing something stupid in this
still complicated position it might be
plus 24 the combat you can still do a do
weird stuff as a human player okay
thanks for watching